[Music]
I lost over a hundred pounds a third of
my weight I was probably my heaviest you
don't ever weigh yourself to heaviest
but I was probably probably over 340
certainly around there and now as I sit
here in front of you I'm probably about
232 there's a fluctuation of a couple
pounds it goes back and forth it's a lot
of weight I did not lose it for vanity I
was pretty happy with myself that I
didn't mind being fat wasn't a big deal
to me
I didn't mind how I looked uh but my
health was getting bad I didn't even
mind how I felt very much in mine you
know not being energetic and stuff but I
started having blood pressure that was
stupid high like you know the like
English voltage like 220 even on blood
pressure medicine and I have two young
children an old dad my children my
daughter was born when I was 50 so I'm
61 now and my life expectancy the
actuary tables were crashing down and
the doctor said that I had to get a
stomach sleeve it was a wonderful moment
because it then gave me the option to go
crazy if you're going to surgically do
something to me to stop me from
swallowing that means they don't to
worry about doing a sane diet I can get
nutty and being given the option to be
nutty was all I needed I realized that
not only am I not good at moderation I
also don't respect moderation anybody I
know who is able to do moderation I
don't like them the people I respect and
love are people that go while I mean I
don't want to go into Kerouac here but
the mad ones I know one brags about
climbing a nice little slope you brag
about climbing Everest so what's my
friend Ray Krone iswhy Cole creare once
cray ray told me that I could lose the
weight but it was going to be really
hard it got really easy once you make
something a challenge it makes it I can
brag about I can do it so I wrote this
book about me it is more first-person
singular in it than a Donald Trump
speech I don't write about you if you
take medical advice from a Las Vegas
magician
you are an idiot who deserves to die you
have to do this for yourself with your
proper medical professionals that being
said the first thing Kramer and I wanted
to do was change my way of eating it
turns out everything about eating is it
is having it's all habitual you think
you have a natural inclination to like
grilled cheese or doughnuts not true all
we eat is habit so I want to take a
couple weeks and change my habit and
what are the really good ways to do that
that we're tremendously for me is what's
called the mono diet which is just what
you think from the root eating the exact
same thing and I could have chosen
anything could've chosen corn or beans
or whatever not hot sludge you but
anything and I chose potatoes because
it's a funny thing and a funny word so
for two weeks I eat potatoes complete
potatoes skin and everything and nothing
added nothing subtractive and I say
nothing subtracted I mean no skin taken
off but also no water you can't cut it
up and make it chips in a microwave
don't take water out of it leave you
know leave the pinnacle but that means
baked or boiled and not at any mealtime
you know get up in the morning in a
potato you don't eat it at lunch or
dinner
mealtimes are obliterated when you
really need to eat weed a potato and
over that first two weeks I lost I
believe 14 pounds so already I'm a
different person but I also reset my
taste buds I don't like to use the word
addiction it's a loaded word and also I
don't think anyone really knows what it
means but I was habituated to a great
deal of salt sugar and oil after two
weeks of potatoes that was gone and the
first ear of corn I had was candy I mean
it was just amazing was so sweet and so
full of flavors and so salty even and I
grew up in New England but there's
wonderful fresh corn in the summer but
it always drenched it in butter and salt
I never tasted it well then after that
two weeks I went to you know what bean
stew and tomatoes and salads but still
no fruit and no nuts
certainly no animal products and I lost
a average his words are careful an
average of 0.9 pounds
a day so I took off pretty much all the
way to three or four months in the
season in a winter because we have so
many calories our bodies are constantly
in summer we're preparing for winter
that never comes which it came for me
and that was 17 months ago so I've kept
the weight off for 17 months now two
years is magic
very few people keep it off for two
years I got seven more months to go I
think I have a shot at it I feel better
I'm happier I'm off most of my blood
pressure meds not all of them takes a
while for the vascular system to catch
up with a weight loss I have more fun I
believe I'm kinder I'm embarrassed about
that because I'm an atheist as I've
covered to this very camera before so I
should not believe in a mind-body
separation but somehow I believed that
my mind could stay healthy and happy
even if my body was falling apart
and I should have ever believed that but
again and now that I'm lighter I feel
lighter and I feel happier and you know
there's a chance my chances of living
longer for my children have gone up
considerably you know I lost my mom and
dad when I was 45 and a year of my life
was in deep deep mourning you know and
there's a very good chance my children
will have to go through losing their dad
and I much rather they do that when
they're a little older than having to do
that when they're 15 turns out that
being my children is more important to
me than chocolate cake all of that
having been said now that I'm a target
weight also this is important I also
didn't exercise while I was losing the
weight exercising his bodybuilding it's
a different thing wait till you hit the
target weight then you exercise then
it's easy than it really does good but
while you're losing weight make it
winter sleep a little more
get sluggish let your body just eat the
fat that you've stored up just the way
you should hibernate a little bit but
eat the fat be a little bit like a bear
now I eat
no animal products no refined grains
extremely low salt sugar and fat another
way to say that same thing as two words
whole plants that's all
ah that being said every couple of weeks
at least two weeks go by but every
couple of weeks I just eat without
thinking I eat you know my my son says
come on dad eat like a man of a pizza
with them I'll have a hot fudge sundae
with my daughter if there's a special
occasion I haven't gone off program in
two weeks up I'll eat whatever you know
what I'm in New York if I haven't had
anything in two weeks I'll have a slice
of really great pizza or maybe a little
bit of corned beef on rye but that is an
occasional rare and appropriate meal
that's a you know a special thing it's
not a cheat I don't cheat because it's
part of my plan the weird thing is
though after the microbiome changes and
after the taste is reset
I do not crave Donuts I do not crave
Pizza I do not crave ice cream or
hamburgers they taste okay when I have
them well that's really not true I
chicken disgust me now
I used to love chicken fried chicken
chicken and waffles it's kind of
disgusting to me
eggs kind of disgust me steaks I light
for a while and now that's kind of
fading away even hamburger everybody I
know that's gone through this we've lost
altogether a bunch of us like 50 400
pounds and I was just talking to a
couple of what we call ourselves cronuts
after red Crone eyes I was talking to a
guy last night he was just saying now
hamburgers have fallen away too I
realized the other day I was in the
airport I was stuck for 10 hours at an
airport and I said you know I'm going to
eat for entertainment because I got
nothing to do and so I just said it's
been a few weeks since I ate badly just
eat whatever I want I realized after but
I've been noticing
I had cookies you know I had a bagel
I didn't eat any meat at all and they
were all there barbecue places you know
those good ribs places
MacDonnell's I just kind of I lost the
taste for it which is really remarkable
because I would have never guessed that
it would have never guessed it and if
someone had told me oh by the way you
just won't want this stuff so the kind
of punch line to this whole thing is
after this whole incredibly restrictive
diet and all of this will power and all
of this climbing a dietary Everest as I
sit here right now on the big thing I
now eat whatever I want but what I want
has changed profoundly
[Music]